contrast the talmud a central Jewish
holy book teaches that Jesus is burning
in Hellfire and excrement so 15 of the
talmud states that even the best of the
Gentiles should be killed given these
irreconcilable differences why do you
insist on using this oxonic term I know
there's a group of people who spend all
day online cherry-picking bad lines from
the tomwood a text that they have no
familiarity with and then trying to spin
that into a giant myth about how Jews
are seeking the extermination of
Christians or some other bizarre
conspiracy theory say look at what they
actually believe about Mary the mother
of Jesus and Jesus himself you will be
shocked if you are a Christian known
throughout history that if Christians
knew what was in the town mud it would
make Christians very angry and so the
Jews were able to conceal a lot of their
most Blasphemous statements about the
Lord Jesus Christ because people didn't
speak Hebrew here's what they say about
Jesus in the
talet just imagine the people back in
the day when they would have to travel
certain distances for months or even
years what is one thing that they would
carry with them the Quran why because
they did not have it on their mobile
devices or their gadgets brothers and
sisters
imagine you have a app the Quran app
which not only shows you how much
rewards you get but reminds you to read
the Quran gives you reminders download
the Quran app now and let it testify for
you on that you read it wherever you
wasum brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are well it's
Christmas season the festive season
where a lot of people are celebrating
Jesus's birthday even though Christmas
has nothing to do with that like in the
Bible it says do not chop down down
trees in the forest and bring and Adorn
them um so alhamdulillah even the Bible
is telling you not to do these Pagan
rituals but anyways Jesus uh I mean
Christmas is known to celebrate Jesus's
birthday
but let's talk about Jesus and what
Judaism actually believes a lot of
people don't know this but it's very
bizarre that Christians um are allying
with zionists and Jews Zionist Jew
should we said for that matter little do
they know that these are the actual
believes and when Ben Shapiro was
confronted Ben Shapiro is an American
journalist like job say
aanus um here is a Christian man
confronting benir and let's see how he
tries to get his way out of this this is
their worst nightmare the tide is
turning against Zionism very fast
brother and sisters America was built on
judeo Christian values however as a
devout Christian I have difficulty
accepting the term given Judaism
rejection of Jesus Christians believe
Jesus Christ is God in contrast the
talmud a central Jewish holy book
teaches that Jesus is burning in
Hellfire and excrement
and while the New Testament tells us to
love our enemies and pray for those who
persecute us s 15 of the talmud states
that even the best of the Gentiles
should be killed given these
irreconcilable differences why do you
insist on using this oxymoronic term
okay so first of all that's a really bad
read of the do second of all the notion
that you can cite any text in support of
the idea that Judaism broad RIT is
somehow disdainful or hateful of
Christians or of or of people who are
not Jewish is in fact a tremendous misre
of Judaism over the centuries and
particularly today I I can cite sections
in the New Testament that I find
personally problematic I can certainly
cite segments in the in the Quran that I
find personally problematic the truth is
I can probably find plac in the Old
Testament that I find personally
problematic that does not speak to what
Judaism is and its historic impact on
the world Judaism is the foundation of
Christianity Jesus himself acknowledged
this the New Testament acknowledges this
the notion that Judaism and Christianity
are somehow completely delink and teach
two completely separate lessons ignores
the fact that the Old Testament is part
and parcel of the New Testament sure
Christians and Jews think different
things of course otherwise I'd be a
Christian or you'd be a Jew if we
thought completely the same thing then
presumably we would have the exact same
religion but the notion that Judaism and
Christianity are completely dink is
wrong as far as Mis citations from the
tomwood or even citations of texts that
are written in the year 500 CE at a time
when Jews were being persecuted by
Christians in the Roman Empire that
seems to me a a real stretch to get to
the idea that Jews today are overall
hateful of Christians I'm not sure that
there's anybody in America personally
speaking who has pushed more people back
to church than me I really don't know
that there is anybody who's done that I
tell Christians literally all the time
to go to church I tell Christians all
the time to re-engage with their faith I
think it is deeply deeply important that
they do I don't try to convert people to
Jud to ISM so I know there's a group of
people who spend all day online
cherry-picking bad lines from the hood a
text that they have no familiarity with
and then trying to spin that into a
giant myth about how Jews are seeking
the extermination of Christians or some
other bizarre conspiracy theory it's a
lie it's stupid and the judeo-christian
values of the nation are quite real
because once again Judaism and
Christianity have an awful lot in
[Applause]
common the guy is bamboo if you see
towards the end of the video he's
actually looking and saying you didn't
even answer my question he didn't even
answer his question oh waffling that's a
bad way of reading the talmud and Jewish
text and and there's few things that he
said there very clearly that oh I tell
sorry I tell Christians to go church and
in the judaic law I'm not allowed to
convert them yes and that's what proves
that they are Gentiles that's why you
are told that you cannot um preach to
them and we know the God knows how long
it takes to be a Jew and even then I
don't think you are you can be an actual
Jew for that matter so you tell saying
to people to go to church only
solidifies how you see the Gentiles
you're just like basically carrying your
idol worship as Muslims we don't do that
you know why because we want Islam for
them we want the Oneness of God the
worship of worshiping one God so we
don't tell them go to church we rather
tell them you should come and worship
God Alone why because we want them to
join our fold we want them to become a
Muslim and it's easy to become a Muslim
it's hard to be a Jew even even the
impossibility and not only that we do
not tell them to carry on the idol
worship you do why because you see them
as Gentile now here's a video which it
breaks down for you by a Christian
Pastor or a priest whatever it is for
that matter spokesman for that matter
where they show you clear categorically
clear of the true beliefs of the talmud
and the Jews for that matter and he
brings evidences look at what they
actually believe about Mary the mother
of Jesus and Jesus himself you will be
shocked if you are a Christian and some
Muslims Also let's watch this for
ourselves known throughout history that
if Christians knew what was in the talud
it would make Christians very angry and
so the Jews were able to conceal a lot
of their most Blasphemous statements
about the Lord Jesus Christ because
people didn't speak Hebrew here's what
they say about Jesus in the toalet
there's sections in there about Jesus in
fact there's an entire book that's been
written by the director of judaic
studies in Princeton University Dr
schaer a Jew he's written a book Jesus
in the talmud so if you want to know
what Jesus has to do with the talud get
his book Jesus in the talmud by Dr
schaer Peter Schaefer is head of the
judaic studies at Princeton University
in his book Jesus in the talmud he
documents and analyzes every time Jesus
is mentioned in the pages of the talmud
keep in mind that the talmud was written
hundreds of years after Christ lived and
so it has references about Jesus in it
and they are hateful Blasphemous
references according to the talet Jesus
was the product of adultery the bastard
son of Mary and a Roman soldier named
panta he spent his early life in Egypt
where he learned black magic idolatry
and sorcery Jesus was born to a
Mary was a she had sexual
relations with many men the father was a
Roman Centurion the talmud further
blasphemes the Lord Jesus by calling him
a fool and comparing him with Old
Testament villains such as balum AEL do
and gesi does the tal talk about the
Jews Killing Jesus but my mind believes
that the the Jews killed him that the
Jews executed him because of certain of
his doctrines and and so forth do you
believe that the Jews killed Jesus um
it's possible the Jews did kill Jesus
right so let's say they did right maybe
he deserved to die maybe he was a
troublemaker let's assume we did so we
killed somebody the talet actually
gloats about Jesus dying young the
passage reads hast thou heard how old
balam was he replied bloody and
deceitful men shall not live out half
their days it follow that he was 33 or
34 years old and you say wait that
passage says bam not Jesus but look at
the footnote at the bottom of the page
bam is frequently used in the talet as a
type of Jesus not only that but in the
Jewish encyclopedia Volume 2 page 469
under balum it says balum given to Jesus
in Sanhedrin 106b and gon 57a Peter
schaer States in his book Jesus in the
talmud that there can be no doubt that
The Narrative of the execution in the
talmud refers to Jesus in fact the book
states there is no reason to feel
ashamed because we rightfully executed a
blasphemer and idolator Jesus deserved
death and he got what he deserved
elsewhere the book states he was a
blasphemer and idolator and although the
Romans probably could not care less we
insisted that he get what he deserved we
even convinced the Roman Governor or
more precisely forced him to accept that
this heretic and imposter needed to be
executed and we are proud of it schaer
said in an article that appeared in
Publishers Weekly concerning his new
book I certainly don't want to harm
Jewish Christian dialogue but dialogue
requires honesty and I'm trying to be
honest I mean there you go guys the
evidence is very clear categorically and
the more they are trying to hide this
the more it's you know uh showing what
kind of this this people they are now
here you can see that guy who a Zionist
Jew they're sitting there like oh we
killed a man who cares we just killed
somebody I mean I mean it's very clear
the worldview with what they're doing in
Gaza in in Palestine exactly they don't
care oh we just killed somebody okay and
it's very interesting Allah subhana in
the Quran says and it says we told the B
Israel the children the children of
Israel if you kill one Soul it's as if
in history they were known to be
murderers and Killers that's why Allah
tells them in the Quran that if you was
to kill one Soul it's as if you could
kill the whole of humanity Allah is
telling you this is so profound this in
itself shows how the Quran is from Allah
the fact that he shows their psychology
what kind of people they that arrogant
sadly these Zionist they have and not
only that the Quran I don't know about
the Bible I don't recall the Bible
defending Mary's onor the Quran has also
one of the reasons the Quran came down
is for what did the Bible come to defend
Jesus's honor or uh Mary's honor no as
far as I know not the Quran also came
down to defend the honor of the prophets
that have been slandered where in the
Old Testament and in the Bible where it
says lot had intimity with his own
daughters Abraham done magic yes Mary
which in the Old Testament me in the
talm is saying that she she's an adulter
they believe she's an look at the stuff
that they're
saying filthy people look at them
adultera she's a can you imagine they're
calling maram I can't even repeat it I'm
so sorry he's a b a s b a s a r d he did
Black Magic he was an idolatra he's a
fool can you imagine this is what they
believe about your God and who is the
one that's defending Jesus on her and
Mar's honor yes peace be upon both of
them who defend it no muslim can be a
Muslim if they deny Mary or Jesus Jesus
who defends honor and like Jesus said in
the Bible I have many things to say unto
you but you cannot bear them now for he
when the spirit of truth shall come he
shall guide you onto all truth he shall
not speak of himself as he hears he
shall speak and he shall glorify me show
me one other religion for Islam to a
side that glorifies Jesus the way
Muslims do I challenge anybody bring me
a single other religion apart from Islam
that glorifies Jesus the way do Muslims
do and you see us as the other the far
right the Christians do you see us as
the other when we are the ones that
believes and glorifies Jesus you cannot
make this stuff up brother sisters and
Ben Shapiro you coward yes you've been
exposed you didn't even answer the
question the guy the questioner was
shocked at the end he was looking around
thinking what kind of nonsense was that
yes what kind of what was that yes
anyways brother and sisters hope this
opens your eyes and share this with your
Christian friends so they can see the
reality and know that the Muslims are
closer to them that's all I have to say
till next time